I've heard that you can go between
characters really quickly and really my
dear Joan you might be Brian yeah yeah
and we're talking later - no that's
sprinkler
that's a sprinkler mr. tortoise it's
fire hydrant you got up for oh yeah I'm
not giving you the part I'm a little
skirt no ask you go ahead so there's a
line in the movie that says whatever you
gave it up for is what your ass I can't
believe you for that out of a movie
these days it's like a Caesar salad okay
[Laughter]
right I have to be on the locals I'm on
the wall outfits are what are the three
sides to Tyler Perry three sides are
there more than three said oh it's how
many more are you Gemini no Virgo but
I'm very much an introvert I am Moody at
times I love to be quiet I love to have
my space and I'm a huge germaphobe there
you go my gosh I think you're the same
person Hey Baby how you doing baby
breathe it in
hey I got this system mind that I've
been walking dead for a long time you
think you can help me with that y'all
need to go see this movie so y'all with
this laugh everything is going on in the
world just laugh and have a good time
damn now go to the movie
[Laughter]
[Music]